I have never really paid a lot of
attention to conspiracy theorists Alex
Jones but when he was on YouTube over
the years I'd sporadically see his
videos there and sort of check out some
of what was going on
now you might remember that Alex Jones
has been banned from YouTube for
violating their terms and conditions but
it came to my attention yesterday I
didn't know this his program is still
going on
he still is touting conspiracy theories
and selling supplements and colloidal
silver or whatever it is that he's
offering it's all happening on his
website though instead of on YouTube
because again he's been kicked off of
YouTube and two or three of our audience
members sent me this exact same clip of
Alex Jones from yesterday everything
about it is odd I think is the way I
would describe it so to set this up Alex
Jones program was always riddled with
conspiracy theories and he was never
super clear when he would present
stories his demeanor was often really
really strange but the clip I'm about to
play for you really takes this to it to
a new level what I'm about to play for
you includes Alex Jones being
particularly incoherent even for his
standards the conspiracy theories are
there but they're even more wacky and
unhinged and it really seems like he may
be actually having some kind of an
emotional sort of crisis maybe as a
result of what's been going on with this
program I don't know let's take a look
at it together and see if we can figure
it out it's all in plain view of these
people they're just put in our face they
want a system where we can't do anything
to stop them that's like Bill Maher the
name of his production company is a kid
love which is you know this is an ample
slogan basically they make sure it's
about having sexual kids all the time
and says it's okay to have sex with you
know kids that have sex 35 year olds
over 12 just incredibly outrageous evil
pathetic stuff of these soulless demons
like Bill Maher but Josh was saying he
had a theory
the only what walnut sauce is and are
gonna say it's the pituitary gland
because they confirm that jimmy savile
and others would torture little kids to
death but they couldn't get regular ones
to kill if everything was to grab a kid
run over the cars they could say oh
there's a police reporting at run over
but they would hurried in the morgue and
they work with different different
governmental morgues and eat the
pituitary gland as quickly as possible
and get high off of it so yes yeah I've
never seen such an outrageous conspiracy
theory presented in such depressed down
and low-energy style I mean particularly
incoherent were normally we understand
what he's claiming fluoride is making
frogs gay right okay it's nuts but we
understand exactly what it is that he's
saying I'm not even sure I fully
understand what he's asserting here the
conspiracy is I picked up that Bill
Maher is a pedophile supporting sex with
12 year olds by grown men and that
walnut sauce is code for the pituitary
gland which I guess someone is going to
morgues and stealing pituitary glands
from people and eating them because they
have a hallucinogenic effect sort of
like recreational drugs of some kind I
mean this is strange even for Alex Jones
and he looks even heavier he sounds
horrible his ad reads for the
supplements are sounding particularly
deflated and again even for his own
standards this is very weird and I went
over to his website Infowars this
morning to see what's going on
he's now promoting his content as banned
videos the latest banned videos and of
course the concept is I guess since he
was banned from YouTube he's playing up
that his content is sort of like
forbidden fruit it's banned but he'll
show it to you on his website there's
also a bunch of new scam products and
supplements available one of them as you
can see here is called turbo force which
is 40 dollars for a one-time delivery
that's just 14 packets but if you get it
auto shipped every 14 days he'll give
you a 10% discount this one is
your go-to source for quick accessible
energy and I looked at the ingredient
list which is available and it includes
you know some pretty normal stuff
vitamin C and thiamine niacin and stuff
like that but also huper zine a which is
an extract from Chinese club moss
isolated into a pure form guarana seed
extract which the indigenous people
would make a tea from these seeds to get
energy as he describes it it's all very
depressing Pat he's ruined lots of
people's lives so maybe I shouldn't be
feeling bad but it's notable the
depression the particularly weird
stories conspiracy theories he's really
not doing well is it yeah and no
pituitary gland in those supplements at
least based off the ingredient list
I've always wondered whether or not Alex
Jones is playing a character or if he's
just genuinely crazy it could be a mix
of both and if you throw in the
depression and general lack of empathy
you can tell the guys in dire straits
right now yeah something is very very
wrong and as a person of course I
empathetic to these the struggle of
others but certainly it seems to me that
it was a bad idea
to have destroyed all those people's
lives for so long with his conspiracy
theories and so what else and there are
consequences that are clearly taking
their toll on Alex Jones at this point
very strange stuff going on over there
one of today's sponsors is privacy calm
slash Pakman this is a free service that
I've actually been using myself for a
while now and I love it you just take a
few seconds to link your debit card or
bank account to privacy coms mobile app
or browser extension for Firefox and
Chrome and what that does is allow you
to instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets five dollars towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link below